thousands gathered from early in the
Iraqi capital and the first visual
reaction to the assassination under the
Iraqi flag and the flags of their own
Shia militia groups they mourned an
Iranian general and his Araki comrades
in Arabic and in Farsi they chant death
to America the coffins snaked their way
to the domed shrine of a revered sixth
century Shia cleric this felt almost
like a state funeral for a military
leader who was Iranian not Iraqi but
whose influence over Shia Muslims in
Iraq and well beyond was huge among the
mourners Iraq's Prime Minister in theory
the country he heads is an ally of
America but after this who knows and
former prime minister Maliki to it was
through these leaders that general
Soleimani channeled Iran's national
interests it's hard to overstate the
influence he was allowed to wield across
the region in Iran's complex power
structure he held arguably more
strategic influence than the country's
top political figures for many years he
has had a direct line to the supreme
leader Ayatollah Khomeini who visited
the generals grieving family they've
called for the killing to be avenged as
the commander of the Kurds for severe
ons revolution regard he trained
financed and equipped proxies across the
region he helped shape Middle Eastern
moments over two decades protecting
President Assad in Syria bolstering
Hezbollah in Lebanon and steering
politics in Iraq he shuttled frequently
between Tehran Beirut and Baghdad
building the axis of Iranian influence
with the assassination President Trump
has gambled where his predecessors would
not both Obama and Bush had
opportunities to kill the general that
calculated the repercussions to be just
too great it is not at all clear what
will come now visiting the generals
daughter Iranian president rouhani vowed
revenge
well now farm Eid and they do not
realize what a big missed
they have made they will see the
consequences of their mistake not only
today but in the years to come in Iran's
holiest city an ominous site designed no
doubt to jolt over the mosque a red flag
hoisted it is their symbol of a battle
to come salamé knees regional influence
was bloody and destabilizing over more
than two decades but his removal by an
American president whose impulse often
dominates is likely to bring only more
chaos to this region mark stone Sky News